merci ma chère merci merci beaucoup oui
en tant que député aussi en tant
qu'ancien magistrat mais comme des
millions de Français je suis en colère
depuis que la ministère de la Justice
est entre les mains de Christian
tobira je le dis je le dis parce que
vraiment depuis son arrivée elle s'est
ingénié à organiser le désarmement pénal
de l'État elle a supprimé les peines
planché contre les récidivistes elle
veut supprimer les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs la rétention
de sûreté pour les criminels
récidivistes et les dangereux criminels
ce désarmement pénal de l'État ça veut
dire quoi aujourd'hui ça veut dire que
100000 peines de prison ne sont pas
effectuées parce que Madame tobira a
renoncé à construire des places de
prison ça veut dire que la délinquence
explose cela veut dire que les policiers
sont au bord du encouragement et que
dire aussi de l'indépendance de la
justice quand on voit madame tobira
convoquer un des plus hauts magistrats
de France le procureur général de Paris
pour lui demander de partir parce qu'il
n'avait pas la même sensibilité
politique qu'elle dans quelle république
vivons-nous aujourd'hui il est temps que
cela change il est temps que nous
retrouvons une justice républicaine
merci